DESTABILIZE EUROPE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT HE NODE TO
KNOW.
>>> FIRST, HERE'S "MY TAKE."
THE JOINT AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND CHINA ON ENHANCING
CLIMATE ACTION WAS RIGHTLY SEEN
AS A STEP FORWARD, BUT FOR NOW,
A VERY SMALL STEP.
IT DID NOT HAVE THE KINDS OF
SPECIFIC TARGETS THAT MARKED THE
2014 AGREEMENT NEGOTIATED BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT
PRECEDED THE BARRIS SUPPORT
WHICH TODAY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SIGNED BY 193 COUNTRIES AND
EUROPEANEN UNION.
BUT IT DID START THE LARGEST
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE WORLD'S TWO
LARGEST ECONOMIES AND GREENHOUSE
EMITTERS.
YEARS AFTER ESSTRANGED
RELATIONSHIPS, IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
U.S. POLICY GOING FORWARD.
SHOULD IT BE FOCUSED ON SOLVING
THE LARGEST AND MOBILE
CHALLENGING GLOBAL PROBLEMS OR
SHOULD IT BE FOLK OUBSED ON
COMPETING WITH CHINA?
AS URIE FREEMAN NOTES IN "THE
ATLANTIC," PRESIDENT BIDEN SPOKE
AT THE U.N. GENERAL ASSEMBLY IN
SEPTEMBER.
>> IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL TRUTH
2691st CENTURY, OUR SECURITY,
OUR PRESS PERTY AND OUR VERY
FREEDOMS ARE INTERCONNECTED AND
MY VIEW AS NEVER BEFORE, SO I
BELIEVE WE MUST WORK TOGETHER AS
NEVER BEFORE.
>> WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE
CUTTING-EDGE ISSUES OF THE
FUTURE SUCH AS CLIMATE,
PANDEMICS, CYBER WARFARE AND
CYBERSECURITY, IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SEE HOW MUCH CAN BE ACHIEVED
WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND CHINA.
AND YET BIDEN HAS ALSO PROMISED
THAT HIS ADMINISTRATION WOULD
PURSUE A POLICY OF EXTREME
COMPETITION WITH CHINA.
HE'S EMBRACED MANY OF DONALD
TRUMP'S POLICIES TOWARD BEIJING
ON TRADE, TECHNOLOGY AND TAIWAN.
THE CONTINUATION OF EACH OF
THESE APPROACHES MAY HAVE
TACTICAL BENEFITS FOR THE U.S.,
BUT AS FREEMAN POINTS OUT, THEY
COULD BE A TENSION WITH THE
STRATEGY FOCUSED ON REPAIRING
AND REBUILDING THE INTERNATIONAL
SYSTEM.
THAT LATTER PATH IS THE ONLY WAY
TO TACKLE GROWING COMMON
CHALLENGES THAT COUNTRIES CANNOT
POSSIBLY ADDRESS INDIVIDUALLY.
NOW FOR THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WAS NO
TENSION BETWEEN THESE TWO
APPROACHES BECAUSE IT DID NOT
BELIEVE IN THE LIBERAL RULES
BASED INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
FOR TRUMP, THE OPEN TRADING
SYSTEM, AMERICA'S ALLIANCES,
FOCUS ON HUMAN RIGHTS, THESE ARE
ALL SCAMS THAT ALLOWED OTHER
COUNTRIES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE EAGERLY EMBRACED A VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH IN WHICH
WASHINGTON WOULD NARROWLY PUSH
THROUGH ITS OWN ADVANTAGE, OFTEN
ITSELF BREAKING RULES AND
VIOLATING NORMS.
YOU SEE RIGHT WING POPULISTS
FROM TRUMP TO RUSSIA'S PUTIN TO
HUNGARY'S OAR BOHN TO TURKEY'S
ERGDEN ALL REALIZE THE
CONSTRAINTS ARE ON THE ABILITY
TO ACT AS THEY WISH WHEN THEY
WISH.
THEY WOULD PREFER A WORLD OF
NATIONALISM AND PROTECTIONISM
AND IF THAT MEANS THE UNRAVELING
OF GLOBALIZATION, OPEN TRADE
SYSTEM, EUROPEAN UNION, EVEN
NATO, SO MUCH THE BETTER.
BUT JOE BIDEN COMES OUT OF THE
TRADITION OF AMERICAN FOREIGN
POLICY THAT BUILT THIS OPEN
RULES-BASED INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH ME ON CNN
LAST WEEK, JAKE SULLIVAN, THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER,
CLEARLY LAID OUT THE GOAL OF
U.S. POLICY TOWARDS CHINA --
>> THE OBJECT OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS TO SHAPE THE
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENT SO
THAT IT IS MORE FAVORABLE TO THE
INTERESTS AND VALUES OF THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS ALLIES AND
PARTNERS TO LIKE-MINDED
DEMOCRACIES.
>> HE ELABORATED ON WHAT THE
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENT SHOULD
LOOK LIKE.
>> AN OPEN, FAIR, FREE
INTERNATIONAL ECONOMIC SYSTEM
AND WHERE BASIC VALUES AND NORMS
THAT ARE ENSHRINED IN THE
DECLARATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS ARE
RESPECTED IN INTERNATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS.
>> NOW, CAN BOTH OF THESE
OBJECTIVES BE PURSUED AT THE
SAME TIME?
IN 2019 SUVEN AND KURT CAMPBELL,
NOW HIS TOP AIDE AT THE
INDO-PACIFIC AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
CO-AUTHORED A FOREIGN AFFAIRS
ESSAY THAT TRIED TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE INTELLIGENTLY, ARGUING
THE KEY WILL BE TO GET RIGHT,
THE BALANCE BETWEEN COOPERATION
AND COMPETITION, WITH CHINA.
THE ESSAY, WHICH MIGHT HOLD THE
KEY TO CHINA'S STRADY LAYS OUT
THE POLICIES IN THE POLITICAL,
ECONOMIC AND OTHER REALMS.
BUT IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE ANY
WHITE HOUSE BEING ABLE TO MOVE
IN A NUANCED, SOPHISTICATED WAY
ON AN ISSUE THAT HAS BECOME SO
INCENDIARY AS CHINA.
IN THEIR ESSAY, SULLIVAN AND
CAMPBELL REJECT A SIMPLE ANALOGY
TO THE COLD WAR BUT ARGUE
CORRECTLY ONE CAN LEARN LESSONS
FROM THAT LONG STRUGGLE.
THEY STRETCH THE CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE OF REBUILDING
AMERICA'S STRENGTH AT HOME WITH
THE GOVERNMENT MAKING
LARGE-SCALE INVESTMENTS IN
SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS IT DID IN THE
1950s AND 1960s.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF ALLIES.
TO MY MIND, THE CENTRAL LESSON
OF THE COLD WAR IS WHAT ALLOWED
THE UNITED STATES ULTIMATELY TO
PREVAIL WAS NOT TOPPLING SOME
PRO MOSCOW GOVERNMENT IN MOSCOW
OR LATIN AMERICA, INTERVENING
MILITARILY IN VIETNAM OR SIDING
WITH RIGHT WING DICTATORSHIPS IN
CENTRAL AMERICA, IT WAS BUILDING
AN INTERNATIONAL OPENING
ESTIMATE THAT SECURED PEACE,
PROSPERITY AND FREEDOM AND
ALLOWED ALL COUNTRIES THAT
PARTICIPATED TO THRIVE AND
PROSPER.
WITH THAT CENTRAL ACHIEVEMENT OF
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY TO BE
SACRIFICED TO GAIN SOME
TEMPORARY TACTICAL ADVANTAGE
AGAINST BEIJING, IT WOULD BE A